ah yes another bicycle this guy's gonna
die too so and sucks there's like parts
of this video that you'll you'll notice
there's a really dick move on one of the
guys but i don't know if he's the
grandfather or the father but check this
out it's different from the one we've
already watched this is different this
new one
this is a yellow stone
oh you're sammy i mean i think
i know we saw this one because i see the
kid
right did we see the mom they're so the
mom's like grabbing that guy [ __ ] out of
the way look the guy runs away from the
kid and this guy grabs oh wow he ditches
the [ __ ] kid well you gotta get the
kid away from there who's the dumbass in
the hat that's what i'm saying i don't
know if it's a grandfather they weren't
happy you bring a child near that
that that buffalo there's i think the
bison's attacking because they're
terrible hats
but why would you bring people that
close to you i know that's the problem
have you ever seen a bison person
they're [ __ ] huge dude of course and
yeah and the orange shirt just casually
walking by he just realized it's behind
him he bear sprayed him or spread him
with something
you have that kid in here you know how
about your grandpa goes [ __ ] the kid
yeah so this guy saved the game how
really grandpa ditched the kid [ __ ]
shut up they're guys saving the kids
yeah i think i start all in the same
family so i don't know what yeah get the
kid out of there because i got gourd he
got gourd under his arm good though but
also
he just felt but a family of idiots dude
this is also god being like i gotta get
rid of some people
but it could teach you don't bring a
child near a [ __ ] wild
not just that you guys don't go near of
course everybody don't go in there of
course and there are signs everywhere
yeah it's yellowstone yeah i know there
are a lot of people that were putting
their [ __ ] toddlers on top of a
[ __ ] boat uh bison think about this
and guess what they shouldn't have kids
they got killed they shouldn't have kids